sorry about the smash window and the
crabs from China from China I don't go
to China for crap gentlemen I have one
order for you it's just the first course
on the first table it's just two super
days thank you okay who's next
I got Auto suits all right your thing is
this
it's a apple pear no bleep blue cheese
and an eggplant stack why is she doing
this is she always on the hot plate she
is she's never quiet which one can you
guys take those off is this not know
I've taken my stuff down that's done
time every window is coming we're
working it hard
they're making us nervous oh my goodness
Carly Carly what I'm cutting what is it
I put this here take this this yours
no that is my New York strap this is
craziness
who joined the cauliflower are you
cooking colocar now yes I know and what
you do cooking don't ya Shinobu truck
yeah this is crazy absolutely crazy what
a mess
wheels are stuck was just sliding on the
[ __ ] grease it's gross Brenda you
know two seconds
sure just stand behind there with it
please stand behind there I'm I'm what
is this
Maceo you guys just clean this and this
from today I don't even know what's back
there for render watts
when was that cleaned it's just two days
ago they got spilled everything that
come in I know
handin ha that is not from yesterday
that is not from yesterday what's that
up there
what's your eyes what's your eyes who
please it's [ __ ]
who is it there's that many earth no
one's clean since you've been here
no one's clean I appreciate your honesty
Miranda yes since he's been here he's
never cleaned it this place is
disgusting you guys clean the floor the
other day didn't you we cleaned the line
the other day we smooth the line you
said you fights to power I never said it
and if you're just trying to make
excuses yes you are are you embarrassed
very at least you told the [ __ ] truth
the owners in denial that has been
poured out for [ __ ] months there
wasn't for there